si usted es un hombre tiene un par de
glándulas en forma de huevo llamadas
testículos los cuales están dentro del
escroto el cual es una bolsa que cuelga
detrás de su pene sus testículos
producen las células de esperma y la
hormona testosterona dentro de cada
testículo existen tubos enrollados
llamados túbulos seminíferos donde su
cuerpo forma células inmaduras de
esperma conocidas como células
germinales o espermatogonias a través de
una serie de etapas llamadas
espermatogénesis los espermatogonias se
convierten en un esperma maduro
el cáncer testicular es una enfermedad
debida al crecimiento anormal en uno o
ambos testículos
generalmente se inicia en las células
germinales cuando los daños genéticos o
cambios llamados mutaciones causan que
las células crezcan de forma
descontrolada las células germinales
cancerosas se agrupan para formar un
tumor el cual continúa creciendo
en la mayoría de los casos estas
mutaciones ocurren en las células
germinales y se llaman tumores de
células germinales
los médicos clasifican los tumores de
células germinales en semi no más o no
seminoma o basándose en la apariencia de
las células bajo el microscopio
generalmente los tumores que no son semi
no más son más agresivos estos crecen y
se diseminan rápidamente mientras que
los tumores que si son semi no más
tienden a progresar a un ritmo más lento
los síntomas del cáncer testicular
pueden incluir una masa indolora en el
testículo o dolor o hinchazón testicular
si usted padece de cáncer testicular su
médico le puede recomendar someterse a
cirugía quimioterapia
y radioterapia
o una combinación de tratamientos según
el tipo y la etapa del tumor
su tratamiento se iniciará con la
extirpación del testículo canceroso por
medio de una objeto mía inguinal radical
en este procedimiento
el cirujano hará una incisión en la
parte inferior del abdomen luego
extirpar a el testículo del escroto
finalmente el cirujano cerrará la
incisión con suturas o grapas
quirúrgicas después el patólogo
examinará el testículo para determinar
el tipo de cáncer que usted padece y
para planificar el tratamiento a seguir
si usted presenta nódulos linfáticos
abdominales agrandados o si las muestras
de sangre indican la presencia de cáncer
después de su arquitecto me a su médico
le puede recomendar la quimioterapia
y la quimioterapia usa fármacos para
detener el progreso del cáncer matando
las células cancerosas que puedan
haberse diseminado a través de los
nódulos linfáticos a otras partes de su
cuerpo
si su tumor contiene las células no se
me no más más agresivas su cirujano
puede llevar a cabo una disección de los
nódulos linfáticos retroperitoneales
luego de que reciba la quimioterapia
durante este procedimiento el cirujano
insertará instrumentos laparoscópicos a
través de pequeñas incisiones en su
abdomen luego extirpar a los nódulos
linfáticos abdominales incluyendo todas
las células cancerosas que se puedan
haber diseminado hacia ellos
si usted tiene un tumor seminoma toxo su
médico le puede recomendar la
radioterapia la cual emplea rayos x de
alta energía para matar las células
cancerosas solo en la zona de
tratamiento
durante este procedimiento el médico
dirige el haz de la radioterapia externa
hacia los nódulos linfáticos abdominales
retroperitoneales el haz de la radiación
matar a cualquier célula cancerosa que
se haya diseminado a ellos